from your research how does porn today
have an effect on society in general I
would say porn really kind of leaks into
different parts of society today it
obviously affects kids and youth when it
comes to the early exposure so many kids
in youth are exposed to porn as such you
know young age but they haven't even had
a conversation about sex and
relationships
with any adults yet so porn really beats
the adults to it when it comes to that
so and I mean obviously it's affecting
relationships you know when it comes to
like expectations and also like the
stories that I've heard from especially
young people explaining to me that like
oh you know I compare myself to what I
see important and I think I need to do
this and I need to do that and you know
I'm supposed to look like this or that
and my partner isn't hot enough or isn't
you know you know doing this or this and
so it's a lot of pressure I think on
many young people today since porn s
currently I would say the the
one-and-only player right now really
setting the standards for our sexuality
and for our you know expectations of
ourselves and each other do you talk to
parents at all and ask them how they
deal with it and how are they dealing
with it in a way that is either
effective or not yeah yeah I do um this
is like this is interesting because I
always see that because whenever it
let's say I've been to a school so I've
talked to the students all day and then
during the night I get to meet the
parents and it's so interesting because
when I'm in a classroom talking to
students they will be totally open and
honest and they will share and they will
be ready to talk about it as if it's
actually affecting them they will share
their own experiences however when I'm
meeting a more adult group I always have
to talk about kids and youth you know if
I'm gonna go into talking about like
grown-ups consuming pouring lot that's
more sensitive to them I find that
I find that kids and youth are more
brave when it comes to talking about
this but I wouldn't I wouldn't count the
adults out for sure not I mean I've had
so many good meetings and just like yeah
meeting adults who are very much on fire
for talking about this but the thing is
I think they they want to talk about it
if they are in fact in very you know
aware of the fact that kids are actually
you know consuming porn but they don't
know how to do it so it's and to many I
think it's a fear when it comes to oh
you know my child is only 8 or 9 or 10 I
don't want to wake a sleeping bear you
know
so I'm like not saying anything and then
when the kid is like 1617 I'm like um
have you heard of condoms you know so
it's just like the gap it's just like
too massive but I do think parents want
to do this for short but I do you also
think we need to equip parents and we
need to give them our facts and tools
and just like the confidence to talk
about this what do you tell them like
how do you tell parents to talk to their
kids about porn say you have I don't
know how how how early kids are getting
access to it but I know kids are getting
iPhones you know before the age of 10
probably yeah for sure yeah I was in
most of the kids in youth that I've
spoken to and you know done interviews
with as well has been six between six
and nine has been like the average age
of the first exposure that's what I've
been told but obviously it's not really
it's not that interesting when you're
eight you know but once you get puberty
then obviously it's going to be more
interesting so 12 is like the average
age for guys to watch porn and a bit
under 14 seems to be the average age for
for girls and so so what do you tell the
parents no comment but what kind of
advice do you give them okay I would
tell you to actually just do it like I
would say just just do it like you
actually don't need to feel like you
have to know everything and have
even though like obviously having facts
and being you know knowledgeable in this
area is obviously gonna help you but if
you do not know anything about it just
like race the topic ask questions and I
will also say like be be smart about it
like put on your poker face and perhaps
ask a question not directly to your kid
about your kid but perhaps ask a
question about that kids you know
friends and classmates and be like you
know oh hey you know do you know if you
have any friends who have perhaps seen
anything online that was a bit you know
did you see anything you kind of reacted
to and I would also like not exclude
like the fun parts online you know like
to not be all you know be so careful and
everything is bad you know but you
really like highlight the good stuff as
well
she's also say to a kid that you know
can we just sit down for an hour and you
could show me like what do you do online
so what's like your favorite thing that
you have ever seen what's the most funny
thing you've ever seen what have you
seen anything that scared you have you
seen anything that you know you lost
sleep over to kind of like include all
of the the good and the bad really and
if the kid is really young just kind of
make a conversation about like online
activities social media just being aware
like this is also content you could come
across a hard thing is that kids young
kids are always looking for thrills and
just find the craziest thing they've
ever seen online yeah and the bad part
about the porn industry I mean it well
it's like any entertainment industry
really is that entertainments always
trying to push the envelope and push it
to the next level
yeah I come up with like the next thing
that people are gonna be like what the
[__] yeah and there's gonna be some
freaks out there some crazy psychos that
like oh yeah they're really into it and
enjoy it I mean it's old it all depends
on their psychology yeah absolutely
but that's the thing that they're never
gonna stop pushing the envelope on it
they're never gonna just keep evolving
it right right and I mean the shock
factor obviously is triggering like
you're saying
and that has to do with like how the
brain works because the brain is gonna
be you know shocked when it sees
something new and something exciting and
even something that will make you
aroused like all of those components
makes for a perfect you know dish so
really I would say to also as a parent
to be aware of the fact that your kid if
your kid let's say you have a 13 year
old who you probably like you know that
this person is or this child is addicted
to pornography or like it's consuming it
a lot I would say to to that parent like
be really careful about like not judging
that kid because you know that brain
works perfectly you know because that
brain responds to what is being
presented online on these major porn
sites and if you get addicted that is
like that's a normal reaction to
watching porn a lot you know it's not
you're not strange you don't have a bad
character you know you lack of morals
you know like you're you're actually
normal so to kind of yeah be aware of
when it comes to shaming and like
guilt-tripping I would say avoid that as
much as you can because and you know
because we got to remember like the porn
industry it's not run and it's not set
up and it's not like it's I mean it's
not being produced by kids right right
like it's being produced by adults so we
are the one who needs to then carry that
responsibility
[Laughter]